[MUSIC PLAYING]
THOMAS MARTIN: So my
name's Thomas Martin.
I'm the founder and
CEO of BigCo, SmallCo.
And so we are a
technology integrator
that brings startup technology
and innovative technologies
to the big company enterprise.
Previously, I was a CIO
and CTO across multiple GE
industrial businesses
and had the pleasure
of leading the effort
to migrate over 9,000
workloads to public cloud.
And today, I'm here
with Brian Johnson.
BRIAN JOHNSON: Hi, my
name is Brian Johnson.
I'm the CEO and
co-founder at DivvyCloud.
Prior to taking on this journey,
I worked at Electronic Arts
for about seven
and a half years,
working on massive
multiplayer online games,
deploying a lot of those
games around data centers
around the world and led
the charge into migration
to cloud in about 2013.
THOMAS MARTIN: Very cool.
All right.
BRIAN JOHNSON: So through
that process of the migration,
one of the things that we
thought was really interesting
is that as we adopted cloud,
we started treating it
like a technology problem.
But at the end of the
day, that actually
wasn't the case, right?
At the end of the day, it was
actually a culture problem.
And what we realized is
that shift to self-service
was incredibly important
for our ability to compete.
All of our competitors were out
there building games, and doing
it much faster, and getting
those products to market,
and learning from
their customers,
and building really cool games.
How could we
continue to do that?
continue to innovate?
Well, we couldn't do that if
IT continued to get in the way.
So we needed to find a way
to allow our engineering
organizations to
access cloud, to be
able to deploy applications,
to innovate through their cloud
infrastructure without
security and IT
really getting in
the way of that.
And through that
process, what we
discovered is it wasn't just
a technology problem, right?
It was actually three
things that came together
in this sort of
perfect storm that
caused an issue for security.
Number one, [INAUDIBLE]
we were moving--
we had more, right?
Just more everything.
We had more servers.
So we were moving
from 500 servers,
although that was not
the actual number.
Thousands of servers
to tens and 20,000's
of instances inside
of AWS and GCP.
So that was really interesting
through that process.
And then we also
had this mechanism
where a number of people
touching the infrastructure
dramatically increased.
It wasn't just the
IT staff anymore.
It was thousands of
engineers all over the globe,
touching infrastructure
and deploying applications,
which led to the third thing.
We were no longer
server huggers, right?
We were basically
having change everyday.
CI/CD process, one little
code change, a bug fix,
tear everything down,
rebuild it back again.
So that led to just
a dramatic increase
in number of changes that were
occurring in the infrastructure
any given moment.
So these three things combined--
number of resources
you had to manage,
number of people
touching those resources,
and how often those
resources were changing
led to this incredibly
difficult problem.
How do we deal with this scale?
How could we possibly,
as an organization,
understand everything
that was changing
and react to it in a
reasonable amount of time,
based on traditional
IT and security
processes we had in place,
which were super slow?
So that was really the
problem we see out there.
This is not a technology issue.
This is a company
transformation issue.
How do you get ahead of this?
And how do you deal with scale?
THOMAS MARTIN: So with that,
let's just kind of talk about--
I mean, what does this
really begin to mean
from a practical aspect, right?
I mean, fairly simple, right?
This is just a simple
three tier architecture.
The opportunities actually
seem quite small, right?
I mean, you've
just got a couple--
you've got a load
balancer, a couple
computes spanning across a
couple of availability zones.
We've got a cloud
storage and Cloud SQL.
Point is, is if you're just
managing it in a small scale
with a single team, not
all that hard, right?
But really, when you
start looking at it,
there's at least 20
plus opportunities
for missed configuration,
just in this simple three tier
architecture.
Think about that when you
begin to migrate, say,
five, seven, 10,000 applications
across an enterprise.
To try to manage this
at any kind of scale
just becomes unwielding.
And what I found was
actually, for ourselves,
in my past
experience, has really
been somewhere between about
100 and 200 applications.
The team, just the whole
structure starts to fall down.
You really have to begin
to think about not only is
that CI/CD process so
important, but it's really
about all the
configurations, not only
real time upon deployment,
but ongoing and on forward.
BRIAN JOHNSON: So what
does this lead to?
Well, in our case, it led to
a couple of different things.
It led to loss of control.
Right?
We're letting engineers go and
sort of deploy [INAUDIBLE]..
That's a great thing.
Right?
You want that innovation.
You need that innovation.
In order to survive
as a company,
you've got to find a way to
compete through innovation.
So it was really important,
but you lose control, right?
It used to be that
any change that's
going to be made in
the infrastructure
went through us first.
So we wouldn't know a problem.
We would see a mistake.
We'd be able to stop
[? it from happening. ?]
That's not necessarily
the case anymore.
And furthermore,
what's interesting is
this happened really quickly,
all things considered.
So it means that you went from
having an IT organization who
had [INAUDIBLE]
process in place to be
able to catch these issues
through the sort of controls
and gateways that
had to engineers
just doing all sorts of
things all over the place.
And the problem is nobody
ever sat down the engineering
organization and explained
to them 20 years of history,
the security issues that we hit.
It's not like IT learned
that stuff the easy way.
We got compromised.
We had problems.
We had issues.
And so we learned
to build processes.
Unfortunately, those processes
really slowed us down.
And the other
thing we recognized
is when we started to
move towards a more
cloud-native approach,
we were like, well, we'll
just do alerting.
We'll just basically
get alerts every time
there's something we
need to pay attention to.
That really quickly
got out of control.
I mean, it just
became whack-a-mole.
There was just no way
to keep up with it.
I have alert fatigue on
here is what we talk about.
And that is getting those
Slack message or emails.
And how do you know which
one to pay attention to?
Where are the important
areas, because the reality is
of 20,000 changes now
you're dealing with,
there's going to be one of those
that might be really important.
And you may have a hard time
identifying which one of those
you need to pay attention to.
So really, this is really about
a signal and noise problem.
With all these
things going on, how
do you reduce all of the noise
so you can focus on the signal?
At the end of the day, you'll
have to leverage automation
to do that.
There's just no way that we can
leverage traditional IT process
to use a runbook,
to correct problems,
to contact the person to talk
to them about making the change.
By the time that's
occurred, the application
has been torn down and
redeployed three times.
THOMAS MARTIN: Yeah.
BRIAN JOHNSON: Right?
So you need to be able
to get rid of the noise,
leveraging automation,
so that your IT staff,
so your security staff, so
your sec ops, your cloud ops
have the ability to
focus on that 10%
that they need to be
dealing with on a more
manual and active basis.
THOMAS MARTIN: And so with that,
you really start to look at
and say that traditional
IT perimeter and processes
that we've always used and
relied upon are ineffective.
You just can't handle those
kinds of changes at scale.
They're still important.
I'm not mitigating the
fact of perimeter control.
And we're going to
talk a little bit more
about that, about how
that begins to fold in.
But it's really so
important, particularly
as Brian talked about to be
able to filter out the noise.
And so as you step back
and think about it,
for those of you who are working
those large enterprise firms,
think about, at least for me,
the IT procurement process,
our development teams literally
had-- they knew in their head
probably an extra 60 to
90 days in the schedule.
They committed.
But they figured by the time
things get through procurement,
backlog of servers making
it to the data center,
by the time they get it in,
they rack it, put it in, put up
the operating system,
get it networked, we're
looking at somewhere
between 90, 120 days.
I've even seen as
long as 180 days
to get procured services
into the data center.
And so those kind of processes,
as Brian was talking about,
when you're standing
up something
to try to detect
it and resolve it,
that resource may have
already been built and gone.
And I know you certainly
experienced that at EA.
BRIAN JOHNSON: Yeah.
I mean, certainly
if we had 180 days,
games get built and thrown
away in 180 days, right?
So you have to be able
to move more quickly.
And I think the other
thing we saw was not just
the time it took to provision.
I mean, that certainly
took a lot of time.
And I'm never going to
rack another server again.
But certainly the
other thing we saw
was just when you were
going through this process
and working with
engineering and trying
to talk about the
problems they're
going to face when they
start to adopt cloud
and you're going to
that transformation,
sometimes people
don't understand
the scale of the attack surface.
And so what I mean is
the offensive nature
of what's going on out there.
So we used to have an exercise
we'd do with our engineers
as they come on board.
We'd have them deploy a server
into a secured environment,
with port 22 open to the
world and completely publicly
accessible.
And we just set like root,
root on password and log in.
And we'd just have them time it.
How long does it take
before that box get popped?
And sometimes when you
go through the exercise,
it opens your eyes to
the amount of things
that are just out there
scanning and looking and trying
to find ways in.
I mean, 10 or 12
years ago, there
was an increase in the amount
of sophisticated exploits
that were being developed.
That's actually started to
dovetail down a little bit,
primarily because it's
not necessary anymore.
People are out there
opening up S3 buckets
or leaving databases
open to the world.
I know that hasn't happened.
THOMAS MARTIN: No.
BRIAN JOHNSON:
Like those things.
And so it's not necessary
to spend time, energy,
and resources in those really
complex exploits, when you can
just scan and find a way in.
And so that's part of
this equation is not only
understanding as security
professionals what
scale looks like internally, but
also training the engineering
organization about what's
important about security,
how they need to
deploy, how they
need to think about
people trying to get in,
because you can help
teach them as they
go through this process.
Everyone's in a race.
Like obviously it's
going to get better.
You're going to get faster
and more innovative.
THOMAS MARTIN: Well, just think
about your own SLAs, right?
I mean, what would be an SLA
from a typical event in a data
center to when you're
going to respond to it?
How much data could be
lost if you had that cloud
storage open to the world?
So those are the
things to think about.
And so how do you
begin to really
think about it from a
remediation standpoint, right?
So the first off is it
needs to be near-real-time.
And so as you go
around, it's really
starting at a harvesting
point, so utilizing
all the access
points, those APIs,
across all those resources, and
harvesting them back real-time,
not only upon creation,
but actually upon change.
That day 2 drift to
also think about.
Things might've been
great as you deployed it
out the CI/CD tool chain.
But what happened after that
point with that engineer?
I honestly don't think--
and one, I really don't
believe people intentionally
do a lot of the configuration
mistakes they do.
But it's that
middle of the night,
day 2 ops when
something's wrong,
I'll change that back
as soon as it's resolved
and it doesn't get resolved.
It doesn't get
flipped back, right?
So you've first got to
harvest that data back in.
Then you want to unify it
so that it's consistent
across all of your individual
accounts, all of your VPCs.
All those resources are then
normalized into a single data
plane.
Then you want to drive
analysis against it.
So as you thought about
establishing those compliance
and security
policies of what does
it mean to our organization
to be compliant,
that's the analysis
that gets done real-time
against those resources.
And then being able
to take action.
What do I want to have
happen when this occurs?
So it's that if,
then, this scenario.
If port 22 is open to the
world, what do I want to do?
Who do I want to wake up?
What immediate action
do I want to take,
not only to protect
the company, but also
from a forensics perspective,
as well as to learn.
Was it the team
that inadvertently
did it to resolve an issue?
Or were we actually breached?
So all that data is captured
and dumped off for analytics.
BRIAN JOHNSON: So I--
THOMAS MARTIN: Yeah.
BRIAN JOHNSON: One
thing here and unify.
THOMAS MARTIN: Sure.
BRIAN JOHNSON: I mean, everyone
saw this morning's announcement
about the multi-cloud
push from Google.
This is absolutely
the right way to go.
I'm super-excited
about their doing this
and they're doing on
top of Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is going
to be the element that
breaks down the barriers and
commoditizes infrastructure.
And so at the end
of the day, it's
going to be really important
from the enterprise
organization
perspective when you're
looking at the
infrastructure layer
that you can have a unified
model, because you're
going to have engineers
who are using Azure.
You're going to have
engineers who are using GCP.
You're going to have engineers
who are using Amazon.
And you can't
build policies that
are going to be just
living in those worlds,
because you're going
to forget about them.
Or they're going to
sort of die on the vine
or in different ways go on.
And as we know in
security, it doesn't matter
if you have 95% coverage.
That 5% is the one
that's going to get you.
So you need to make
sure you create
a holistic strategy and holistic
policy as you move forward.
So how do you do that?
Well, there's lots
of different ways
to think about dealing with
this using remediation.
One is in a development
environment,
your remediation
might be slightly
different than as your
production environment.
And your development
environment,
you can say, look, engineer, you
want do some latency testing.
I work for a big bank.
We are not allowed to have
servers outside the United
States.
But you want do some
latency testing.
So in the development
environment,
you can spin up an instance
in Asia Pac for the next two
hours.
Two hours later,
our system's going
to automatically come
back and clean it up,
make sure everything's OK.
But when you move that same
application to the staging,
you may not actually have
that ability to do that.
You might leverage more
faster remediation.
A server comes on in Asia
Pac, it's killed instantly.
But you still want to let
them have that ability
to try new services and
do more things, right?
You don't want to lock them
down using preventive controls,
because you need them to go
in there and try new things.
You need them to innovate.
And if you block them
at the top layer,
they're just going
to go around you.
They'll go create an account
and try it themselves.
And that's the worst
thing you can be in.
Being compromised is bad.
Being compromised and not
knowing it is way worse.
So embrace this.
Help them innovate.
Help them learn.
Go through that
process with them
and leverage
remediation in real-time
to be able to
provide flexibility
about how they do that.
But then when you
get to production,
this is where you
may want to leverage
some preventative controls.
The cloud providers today
provide different ways
to do preventative controls
and lock down certain services
from being used.
So as you're taking your
engineer through this journey,
you want them to
each stage understand
it's a little bit
more stringent,
it's a little bit tighter,
it's a little bit harder
to do what you're going
to do if it doesn't fall
inside the parameters
of what we've approved,
so when they get in production,
it just doesn't work.
But they're not
surprised by the time
they get there, because the
whole way through the journey
you've been teaching them.
And what's more important
about that is it's
not just about
enforcing a policy
and then just running away.
It's about engaging them.
It's about bringing them into
the conversation and saying,
what is it you're
trying to accomplish?
What are you trying to do?
Let me help you find a
secure way of doing that.
Help them innovate and help
them along that journey.
THOMAS MARTIN: Let
me interject there.
And Brian's going to talk
about it on the next slide.
But the thing about it too,
it's, as he's mentioned,
this funnel of restriction.
You're providing
guardrails that are
much wider in that early
stage to generate innovation.
But by the time you
are at stage three,
it's least privileged, right?
In fact, in many
cases, it's just
going to be machine-only
privileges that
are enabled in production to
be able to run those services.
And so we'll talk later
here in the next layer
about how you get there.
BRIAN JOHNSON: Yeah.
So let's talk about
these different layers.
It's sort of like
almost thinking
about super-fine-grained up
to a more coarse grain, right?
So when you're in what
we call protect mode,
this is where you're leveraging
real-time remediation
to go in and clean
up after things
or shut things down or clean
up security groups, whatever
it might be, identify databases
that have not been connected
to in a long time.
All those different
elements are going in,
automating, cleaning up,
fixing, that kind of stuff.
And you're protecting your
environment on a regular basis.
Then you have your
in-flight checks.
So this is your
ability to take things
like Terraform or CloudFormation
templates or anything
you need to work with to be able
to deploy into your environment
and provision, maybe
Helm Chart, where you're
able to deploy into
that infrastructure
and have the engineers
integrate with a tool that
will allow it to check those
things as they're doing it.
So when they go into
the CI/DC process,
it checks in with
the system and goes,
hey, I'm about to build
these 10 resources.
This is what it looks like.
Is this OK?
Have the CI/DC process then
either pass it and say,
yeah, you're allowed to do
this, because it's development,
but we're going to tell
you this is a problem,
or have it just
straight fail the build.
You want to integrate and bring
security into their world, not
the other way around.
Again, if you try
and do that, they're
just going to find it
annoying and go around you.
So how do you go-- how do
you bring it in, right?
So those in-flight checks
are really important.
And then finally, these
sort of landing spaces,
this idea that as you
provision accounts,
you do it in an
automated fashion.
And when you do that
for projects or teams
or whatever it might be, you go
in and start slapping controls
around it at provision time.
And this might be a
mixture of remediation
and preventative measures.
You might enforce some sort of
ability with CI/CD pipeline,
where it's getting
checked as it goes.
All those sort of tighten
things around as you
go into more production
and preventative accounts.
There we go.
THOMAS MARTIN: And
so those really go
in combination, right?
So those coarse-grained
or those big mindsets
that say, these are
never to be violated,
if you will, down
to that mid-grain,
where, as Brian talked about,
you may put a warning there
in that dev cycle, but you're
not going to shut it down
immediately, because
you also are facing
into that cultural
shift, so you also
want to educate engineering
as to why we are going
that direction, down to those
fine-grain controls that
not only take care
of upon launch,
but really that drift that
can occur day 2, day 30.
So those really combined
with some of things
that we talk about on the
previous slide around the cycle
aspect gives us--
for those leaders in the
room, gives us that ability
to become more the
department of yes,
to drive innovation
for your company,
versus the department of no.
BRIAN JOHNSON: Look, I think
the high-level key takeaway here
is that as everyone
goes down this journey,
you need to define a strategy
for the organization.
This is not a--
this is why we started out
talking about the fact this is
not just a technology problem.
This is how a business
is going to transform.
When I was at EA and
we were building games,
the introduction of
cloud didn't just
change how we deployed
our applications.
It literally changed what
applications we built.
It changed what games
we took to market.
It changed which games we
decided to stop developing on,
because we were able
to do it faster.
So it's a huge business
transformation.
So as you go through
this process,
you decide how
security, how IT, how
cloud ops is going
to address this,
it's important to think of
about it as a holistic strategy.
So when we talk
about those layers,
all the way from
development into production
needs to be taken
into consideration,
and how you engage
your engineering staff
and teach them as they go.
THOMAS MARTIN: Absolutely.
And I think, as Brian mentioned
earlier around filtering out
the noise, we can't rely on the
traditional just the perimeter
security control and just
providing notification.
OK.
It's great to know that there's
a theft happening in aisle 5.
But have we filtered out the
noise and know exactly where
and pinpoint what is happening,
where it's happening,
and how to resolve
it, and then be
able to take that
action to remediate it
in a time of cloud speed?
BRIAN JOHNSON: The
other thing-- so we're
out there on a regular basis
working with large enterprise
customers, solving for
this strategic problem.
And one of the things
that we've found
is that companies that
tend to have most success,
are able to get moving quickest,
have an established cloud ops
team.
This is sort of
interesting, because when
we talk about security,
there's this desire
to think about traditional
infrastructure security.
This is about analyzing
network traffic
and identifying external
threats and coming up
with preventative measures
to react to those threats.
But the security problem
we're facing right now
is different than what
we've seen before.
I used to do exploit development
professionally for a while.
And so from the
offensive side, you're
thinking about things
slightly different.
You're thinking about how
to get into a black box.
From the security side, when
you're defending against that,
you're looking at traffic
to try and figure out
what people are
throwing at you, what
do they know about you
that you don't know,
and so on and so forth.
When you're dealing with
the cloud ops side of things
and helping
engineering teams grow,
it's much more
about understanding
what they're doing and what
their needs are, making
sure they don't make mistakes.
It's an internal threat.
And it's very different,
because it turns out you
and them are on the same side.
You're not fighting one another.
So you have to find a
way to embrace that.
And what we've found is
by establishing a cloud
center of excellence,
a cloud ops team that's
going to be focused on security
from a cloud perspective
and what that means to
the internal organization
means you get a lot more
innovation a lot quicker.
THOMAS MARTIN: I think to add to
that is my experience has also
been that having
that focal team,
that cloud ops team also
helps as an accelerant,
not only from an
adoption perspective,
but also from an educational,
cultural perspective
across the entire
organization as folks
begin to transition out of
that data center mindset.
In many cases,
you're going to be--
I mean, my expense
has been, again,
that most organizations
of that size
are going to always be hybrid.
They're going to have their
data center with their large ERP
systems and others that
will remain on prem.
But to be able to manage that
mindset across the board,
it helps to have
that cloud ops team.
BRIAN JOHNSON: Absolutely.
[MUSIC PLAYING]